a World Cup buildup like no other
migrant workers brought to England
training
a managed events seeming far removed
from the stores are suffering and those
the fa wants FIFA's help securing
compensation for
we saw that letter that Johnny fantino
and fatness Mora sent to all the World
Cup teams telling you not to lecture not
to moralize to focus on the football
what was your reaction to that letter
we've always said we'll use our
platforms as positively campaign for
social change where it's relevant to do
so we think it is in this case and we'll
continue doing that
England are determined to use their
presence in Qatar to raise awareness of
social issues it's why they're meeting
migrant workers and the Wales team have
also met some of those who've endured
low-paid conditions to build up this
country to host the first tournament in
the Middle East the Welsh are here at
their first World Cup in 64 years and
they've now held their first training
session here in Qatar Wales Captain
Gareth Bale will be wearing a one love
armband like England's Harry Kane
highlighting anti-lgbt laws while we
informed FIFA that we were through the
whole season going to be wearing one
love armband across all England teams
male and female and we're absolutely
committed to doing that they haven't
given us any response to our letter so
we'll um we'll be wearing the armband I
feel a bit frustrated they've ignored
your letter
not really we made it very clear that we
were going to be wearing the armband
across all competitions and that's what
we'll be doing are you expecting any
punishment for wearing them here at the
World Cup I think there's a possibility
that we might be fined and if we are
then we'll pay the fine we think it's
really important to show our values and
that's what we'll be doing
activism has already produced change
here the World Cup platform is being
used to protect the rights game for
workers and to secure further reforms
Rob Harris Sky News alwakra in Qatar